Please welcome, Ayesha Curry!
(audience clapping)
Hi! Thank you so much for having me.
I love your magazine.
Thank you so much. It's crazy to see it in your hands.
I actually can't believe it.
I'm like, gonna start crying.
I just, I mean, your cookbook.
Your magazine.
You have a kitchen line, a home.
You're building
an empire and a lifestyle brand
that we can all embrace and then live in.
Was that something that you consciously thought?
Or did it roll out slowly?
Was your end goal to rule the world?
Or was it like,
(woman laughing)
steads to get there?
I, so, it's so interesting.
I'm gonna be 32.
And I feel like it's been a journey.
So I'm finally at the point now,
launching Sweet July, where this is truly my voice
and my messaging and,
the whole hope with it is just
for people to find that bright spot in their life.
And so, Sweet July is the title and the name of the brand
because all of my kids were born in July.
I got married in July.
And it's one of the happiest times of my life.
And I was like, I need to figure out
how to carry that through every single day.
It shouldn't just be one month out of the year.
And so the goal is to encourage everybody
to figure out what that Sweet July in their life is,
and implement those little things
that make them happy every day.
Okay,
not only is that going into my gratitude list tonight.
Woo!
That's a real think-piece.
I mean, I'm really beyond admiring
everything that you're doing.
And, you are also the first woman
since Oprah, you know,
to launch a magazine like this.
It's so insane.
It's so nice and special and I'm just honored
to be able to, you know, have space on the magazine shelf.
Cause I didn't see much of it,
many people that look like me growing up
when I would go out and look for magazines.
So it's just nice to have that diversity on the shelves.
And you're doing it in such an elevated,
and chic, and beautiful way.
Now, your husband, Steph Curry.
I mean, #goals. Both of you.
Most, I think, because of the work that you do
for your community.
I literally was like,
I could spend the entire time with you
talking about the incredible accomplishments
that you are doing for others.
Thank you.
We, about,
almost two years ago now, started our non-profit,
Eat. Learn. Play.
And, it couldn't of come at a better time.
Because it was right before the pandemic hit.
And so, we've been able to team up with our local partners
to provide meals for kids and their families.
We're at almost over 15 million meals,
just in the midst of the pandemic.
And so, it's been
(audience clapping)
it's been insane.
(audience cheering)
But also devastating. The fact that, you know,
the need keeps growing.
And so, we're just trying to stay
as boots on the ground as possible
and keep everything growing.
But we've been so grateful to the community
and everybody that's been willing to step up
and lend a helping hand.
Cause it's not just us two, that's for sure.
Well, it is overwhelming
your generosity and the attention to detail,
and the amount that you give and do.
However! I wanted to ask you really quickly,
if he's still drinking the cranberry juice,
draining it empty,
and then putting it back in the fridge?
(woman laughing)
Cause, like.
I was like, the audacity!
Like, who does that?
I was so mad.
And then he tried to blame it on our eight year old.
He was like, oh, I think.
I'm like, you cup of cranberry juice
is sitting right in front of you!
It wasn't her.
(woman laughing)
It was you.
Dad.
I loved that story so much.
(upbeat pop music)